-The president and his allies
have decided
on a closing message for the
final days of the campaign.
Whine about social media and
pretend the pandemic is over.
For more on this, it's time
for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
There's a lot you can say
about Donald Trump's
inner circle and the leadership
of the modern Republican Party,
but when you boil it down, it's
basically just a collection
of gigantic weirdos.
They're the people who
collect ceramic pigs
and sit by their windows,
writing down
license plate numbers
for no reason.
Take, for example, house
minority leader Kevin McCarthy,
who showed up to one of Trump's
rallies yesterday and claimed
Republicans are going to
take back the House.
McCarthy then belched up this,
I think,
English sentence about
House Speaker Nancy Pelosi.
-I want you to watch Nancy
Pelosi hand me that gavel.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And I promise you this,
I won't bang her with it,
but I'll bang the end to the
socialism and, yes, to America.
-What now?
"I'll bang the end to the
socialism and yes to America"?
That sounds like a poorly
translated leaflet
dropped on Moscow during
the Cold War.
Why do all these guys talk like
rip-off dollar store action
figures made in Eastern Europe
that your grandma would get you
for Christmas?
Oh, wow, it's a Fuzz Goodyear?
Let me pull the string.
-Infinity is where I'm going
and maybe even a little bit
further!
-The leaders of the modern GOP
are basically just
a bunch of goofy old puds.
Yeah, I said it, puds.
The type of guy who's still
working at
your hometown bowling alley
30 years after high school
because he gets
free disco fries.
"Plus I get all the shoe spray I
can huff, and that is a lot."
For example, Republicans held a
hearing on big tech companies
yesterday just to complain about
supposed social media bias
against conservatives,
which it's not a thing.
Now, there are progressives,
like Elizabeth Warren
and tonight's guest,
Bernie sanders,
who really do want to break up
big tech monopolies
that have consolidated
too much power.
But Republicans just
want to whine
about mean tweets they
don't like.
The best example of that
came from Wisconsin Senator
Ron Johnson,
when he complained about an
obviously satirical tweet.
-Mr. Dorsey, you talked
about your policies
toward misinformation and that
you will block misinformation
if it's against civic integrity,
election interference
or voter suppression.
Let me give you a tweet that
was put up on Twitter.
It says, "Senator Ron Johnson
is my neighbor
and strangled our dog, Buttons,
right in front of
my 4-year-old son and
3-year-old daughter.
The police refuse to
investigate.
This is a complete lie,
but important to retweet
and note that there are more
of my lies to come."
How could that not be a
violation of voter suppression?
Obviously, if people think I'm
strangling my neighbor's dog,
they may not show up
at the polls.
That would be voter suppression.
-"And another thing, Mr. Dorsey,
last night, my door bell rang
late at night.
So I went to answer it,
and when went to answer it,
there was a flaming bag of poo
on my front step so I tried to
stamp out the fire,
but I got poo all over my shoes.
This is clearly an act
of voter suppression
by the neighborhood teens.
Because if I have poo-poo
on my shoes, I'll be too
embarrassed to go vote!"
The bigger problem here is Ron
Johnson thinks his constituents
might actually believe that he
strangled his neighbor's dog
and, yeah, okay.
I can kind of see it.
With that said, Jack Dorsey
looks like a dog serial killer.
Like straight up a guy who
took out multiple dogs.
In Ron Johnson's
corn chowder brain,
a joke tweet about a senator
is voter suppression,
but invalidating mail-in ballots
and making people wait
hours to vote isn't.
He's like a guy who parks his
BMW in a fire lane,
then loses his [bleep]
when his car gets towed.
"This is voter suppression!
How am I supposed to get
to the polling place now?"
And then there was Tennessee
Senator Marsha blackburn,
who asked the CEO of Google if
the company was still employing
someone who criticized her.
-Is Blake Lemoine,
one of your engineers,
still working with you?
-Uh, Senator, I'm familiar
with his name as a name.
I'm not sure that he's currently
an employee.
-Okay.
Well, he has had very unkind
things to say about me,
and I was just wondering
if you all
had still kept him
working there.
-Man, Fox News was right.
Cancel culture
is out of control.
She sounds like she's
asking to speak the manager
about a sales assistant
at Costco.
"Is Madison still working here?
She had very unkind things to
say about me when I tried to
sample the pizza rolls
in the frozen aisle.
Very hurtful things
about how I'm not supposed
to open the box."
This is the fundament reality
of the modern GOP.
They're all Donald Trump.
He complains about social media,
so they complain about social
media, even though most of them
don't have the tech
savvy to handle
the laundry room
bulletin board.
"Coffee table for sale.
What the hell does OBO mean?
This is unfair!"
This is what the GOP is now.
They've failed at everything
else, so they're reduced to
whining about mean tweets and
trying to get people fired.
And in their warped minds, they
think this is more important
than the deadly pandemic that's
killed 227,000 Americans.
Eric Trump actually claimed
supposed social media bias
against conservatives was the
biggest issue in the election.
-You better believe they also
have their fingers on the dial.
I mean, if I put something out
that they disagree with,
the numbers are down.
I mean, I can just see it based
on engagements and likes.
You can, too, on yours.
They are censoring us.
They don't do it to
the other side.
It's gross but Americans
are seeing through it.
Believe me, Americans
see through it.
I'm telling you, people
aren't happy about it.
I think it's actually become
probably the number one issue
in politics in the last
couple weeks.
-Yeah, man, it's
definitely the number one issue
in politics right now.
In polls, it's right above
Hunter Biden's laptop,
Lesley Stahl was very
nasty to Mr. Trump,
and why did Ron Johnson
kill that dog?
He was looking at me funny!
Buttons had to go.
Of course, none of this is
working with voters, which is
why Trump is way down
in the polls.
Now, a lot can still happen
before the election, and polls
can be wrong, as we've
learned before.
But right now, the story seems
to be pretty consistent.
Joe Biden has a large
national lead.
Much easier path to
270 than Trump.
Two national polls yesterday
showed Biden up by 12
and 11 points each.
Which, somehow, gives me
even more anxiety
than if the race was closer.
It's like when your wife says
she wants you
to go on that guys trip to Vegas
for the weekend.
You're like, "Okay, so
what are you gonna do?"
"Oh, nothing."
"You won't be like lonely?"
"Oh, no, I'll be fine."
"Well then I'm not going!"
And we have to remember
not to read too much
into any single poll.
Just yesterday, one poll had
Biden up 17 points in Wisconsin,
while another had him up only
five points in Minnesota.
It's the kind of maddening poll
result designed to keep you up
all night mainlining Xanax and
digging through cross tabs.
"Alright, let's see here.
Biden is overperforming with
liberal suburban women under 35
who drink Tazo tea
and play tennis, but
underperforming with
centrist NASCAR dads over 50
who refer to the bathroom
as their 'office.'"
Again, anything can happen,
which is why you should take
nothing for granted.
But the fact is, everyone's
looking at the same
polling data.
The Trump campaign knows they
can't campaign
against Joe Biden.
So, they've decided instead
to campaign against reality.
Specifically, the reality
of a deadly pandemic
that is once again spreading
rapidly out of control.
New cases are at record numbers,
and hospitals are filling up.
Over 1,000 Americans died
just yesterday alone.
Unless we do something
different, the bleak reality
is only going to get bleaker,
as Dr. Anthony Fauci explained
on Wednesday.
-This is going to get worse
because we're going more into a
colder season
as we get through the fall
and into the winter.
With the holiday season going,
we've got to do something
different.
We just can't let this happen.
We're going to have many more
hospitalizations and that will
inevitably lead to more deaths.
So this is an untenable
situation.
-It's only an untenable
situation
if you're a sane person capable
of empathy and compassion
and not, you know, a sociopath
who dances at his rallies
during a deadly pandemic like a
hungover little league umpire
calling strike three.
"Strike three!"
"But Mr. Trump, that was only
strike one."
"You're out of here!
You're out of here, kid!"
Trump and the GOP just don't
care about the pandemic.
They don't care that hospital
ICUs are filling up,
that hundreds of Americans
are dying every day.
Trump keeps showing a flagrant
disregard for human life
by holding giant superspreader
rallies in hot spots
and by pretending that
the pandemic is over,
and that the virus just
isn't that deadly.
-With the fake news, everything
is COVID, COVID, COVID, COVID.
I had it.
Here I am, right?
People are getting better.
And, you know, you're immune.
That's why I could jump right
there, see those men?
I'll kiss the men.
I'm not into that, but I will
kiss every man there, and kiss
every woman there,
if you don't mind also.
They won't catch anything.
-I love how he throws in "I'm
not into that," after saying
he'll kiss the men, like he's
giving the gay community
the sad news.
I'm sure they all had their
hopes up.
"What did he say?
Oh, never mind.
False alarm, guys."
Also, if you went out in the
crowd and started kissing
people, I'm pretty sure they'd
catch something.
I wouldn't be surprised if
Trump's blood is full of those
bacteria they usually only find
in Arctic ice core samples.
And, plus, the Trump White
House, remember, is a hot spot.
It's probably filthier than a
bus stop bench in midtown.
Forget COVID.
Has anyone fumigated that place
for bed bugs?
You just know Trump leaves
Diet Coke rings everywhere,
and uses the curtains as napkins
like Oscar Madison.
I bet if you shined a blue light
on that place,
it would look like the Hayden
Planetarium.
If Biden wins, they should just
tear it down and build a new one
across the street like
they did for the Mets.
Because if it worked for
the Mets -- what?
Oh, it didn't?
It didn't work for the Mets?
How bad is it?
Oh, it's bad?
Well, at least you still
have the Jets.
What?
Trump has also decided to use
his rallies to once again
discredit one of the most
powerful tools we have in
fighting the virus,
universal mask wearing.
In fact, he seems to have some
very weird ideas about
how you're supposed to
eat with a mask on.
As he explained yesterday, Trump
thinks instead of just
taking it off, you have to get
the food through the mask.
-In California, you have a
special mask.
You cannot, under any
circumstances, take it off.
You have to eat
through the mask.
Right?
Right, Charlie?
It's a very complex mechanism.
And they don't realize
those germs,
they go through it like
nothing.
They look at you with that
contraption
and they say that's an easy one.
I'll go right through
with the food.
How about California where
you're supposed to eat
with the mask?
Can't take it off.
-Is it possible you're
confusing a mask with a bib?
"You have to tie
the mask around your neck
and put it over your
face before you eat.
You can't see the food
on the plate.
That's why they put a picture of
what you're eating on the bib."
Also why is he narrating the
thought process of a germ?
He sounds like a doctor
giving a Ted Talk
after a massive head wound.
"The germs look at you and say,
'I'm going right in
with the food,' and then they
hitch a ride on the Big Mac,
or Whopper, either one, and
slide down your throat
into your stomach, where
they pretend to be normal cells
to blend in, and then
when no one's looking,
they sneak down,
down to your butt,
and that's where
the farts come from.
We love the farts, don't we?
Oh, they make us laugh
with their silly sounds.
Silly sounds.
Not crooked Joe.
Doesn't love the farts."
There are less than five days
left in the campaign,
and the ruling party has decided
to ignore the raging pandemic.
Instead they're spending their
time whining about social media
and plotting ways to steal the
election through the courts.
It's a deeply dangerous,
sociopathic movement
that's incapable of governing.
And if we soundly repudiate
them next week,
then we celebrate by saying --
-Yes to America!
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver cooks and
brings over 2 million meals
a year to men, women,
and children
living with HIV/AIDs, cancer,
and other serious illnesses
and they need your help.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the "donate" button.
Stay safe, wash your hands,
wear a mask.
We love you.